next week Six Nations rugby match
between Island and Italy has been
postponed because of concerns over Co
vid 19 Italy is experiencing the biggest
outbreak of corona virus outside of Asia
322 people are infected while 12 people
have now died within the last hour the
head of Islands Rugby Football Union
said they will work to reschedule the
affected matches we had a very positive
meeting with Minister Harris and his
advisers where we requested an
instruction as to the staging of the RMV
Italy international matches over the
weekend of 6 to 8 May at the meeting we
were informed that the national public
health emergency team has determined
that the series of matches should not
proceed in the interests of Public
Health the ifu is perfectly happy to
comply with this instruction we will
immediately begin to work with our Six
Nations partners to look at the
possibility of rescheduling those three
matches I would hope to have an update
on that in the coming days let's speak
to our Island correspondent Stephen
Murphy and Stephen it's interesting
isn't it in the last few weeks since
this outbreak we've seen the fall of a
number of key sporting events and it
seems like Rugby Six Nations is next
yeah I mean the writing had been on the
wall really for this event since
yesterday afternoon when we saw the
Minister for Health Simon Harris that's
who Philip Brown was referencing there
the Minister of Health here in Ireland
Simon Harris he had said it that it was
now the Irish government's view that
this match should not go ahead and ever
since then it was very difficult to see
how the Irish Rugby Football Union could
come to any other conclusion other than
to call this match off however they were
clearly a little unhappy about how the
information at being communicated on his
way into that meeting Philip Brown said
it was unfair that the burden fell on
the I our view alone to make this
decision they were inside here at the
Department of Health in Dublin for about
an hour or so trashing out the details
he emerged as you saw there he gave
quite a short statement to the assembled
media but the key point obviously is
that this match the Six Nations game
between Ireland and Italy which are
scheduled to take place here in Dublin
on March the 7th is now off also the
women's matches and the under-21s game
as well they have been postponed as well
they won't be counseled entirely as you
heard there Philip Brown will be working
with the Six Nations tournament
organisers to try and find a way to
postpone this there is some sort of
precedent for this back in 2001 the Six
Nations was hit by the foot-and-mouth
disease crisis and several games were
postponed right down as far as the
autumn Ireland ended up playing matches
in September and October that year to
complete the tournament so I would
imagine they would be looking very hard
at postponing rather than an outright
cancellation but it certainly raises
questions as well about other games in
the tournament England are due to travel
to Italy the following weekend to play
if Lea in Rome I imagine the authorities
would now be looking very closely at
that we also asked Simon Harris as well
about the st. Patrick's Day festivities
it's a huge event here in Ireland half a
million people were lined the Dublin
streets here to watch the parade what is
the Irish government going to do about
that will they allow that sort of mass
gathering to go ahead he said that the
situation wasn't quite comparable
because for the earthly game about two
and a half three thousand Italy fans
have made arrangements to come here I
don't forget rugby in Italy it has its
stronghold in the north of the country
so he said the threat was much more
present for that event rather than st.
Patrick's Day that is a little bit
further down the line
certainly as of now and as we expected
the Ireland V Italy game in the Six
Nations is off